大家好,我今天这个是今天早上其实那个周会的一个重录
那个周会时候呢有一些讨论我觉得比较比较敏感
所以我把那些敏感信息给去掉以后重录了一下
然后上周上周二上周三的时候美国Liberation Day
那个我们叫解放日
那把大家钱包都给解放掉
所以我觉得现在市场上呢我觉得是这样
你们可能是绝对不需要我的时候
因为我们从今年12月1月就开始说到
那个美国可能会有tail risk 微波风险
其实更加需要去关注微波风险或者是怎么处理微波风险
时候是风险没有发生的时候
而现在风险已经发生了
那么这个风险发生的其实就是那个美国的tariff关税
这关税对于中国欧洲全世界全部都加了一遍
所以一旦这样的一个关税成色出来
我们认为是已经发生了微波的风险
那么现在我们认为就是我上周也讲到对于经济基本的预期
对于经济基本的预期就是GDP要到0.5%到1%
然后静态来看那个通胀的话到4%
那么动态来看呢因为
股票下跌财富减省可能会导致这个经济数据进一步下跌
所以呢就是通胀可能没有那么严重
但是经济会更差
美国可能会经历一个季度到两季度的衰退
那么这个一个季度到两季度衰退对应着我觉得S&P的合理的加为
4000到4800
那极端情况下可能会集串
那么如果说没有
你把这个关税给直接取消的话
那当然了就是那个经济会会
就是这个市场马上就会涨回去马上逼返
但是我们现在认为就是对于特朗普政策
对于GOP他们的政策
我觉得来说
他是一个非常明确的
这是他的核心价值观政策
反全球化
然后美国优先搞关税
然后这个呢是他的民粹性的价值
民粹代表他的选票
民粹性的价值价值观的政策不大会变
而且特朗普这个人的本质他
一向以来
他是一个投铁的网红富二代
那这个网红富二代和很多人一样
你要理解这网红富二代他的行为模式
就是一旦犯错他就投铁干到底
然后惹着一粒鸡毛以后他就躲起来不晚
所以这种这种类型的人和政策
他的回头的概率很小
所以我们就把他回头做一个upside risk
base case就是他不会变
那不会变的话呢
就是我觉得没到底
市场呢会继续
就不是在这个位置上可能会继续下跌
但是市场基本上
你会看到趋势是往衰退走的
那那个美国股票市场就会继续下跌
那么短期里面我确实觉得
就是你会看到整个市场已经跑到6个sigma
那这个是global book
global prime book对冲基金的flow
flow这个事情呢
会比你们看K线多的多
flow这个意思就是我有多少人进卖路
多少人进卖出
那这个是直接带动市场涨跌的
那我们看这个flow
4月3号3号4号
其实昨天已经有点逼反
那个加跌以后有点挥稳
所以看到比较说4月3号4号
那个flow基本上和2009年最惨的几天差不多
所以你看global book是6个方差
这是6个方差
3个方差就是99
两个方差就95
然后美国的是4个5个方差
基本上这个就和2020年的这个疫情的时候是一样
所以你会看到这个情况
你认为短期里面确实那个空头的多头
就是多头一点就着
多头地上全是多头来了
一点就着
所以有可能会逼反
但有可能会反弹
而且是会比较大的反弹
但是每一次那个雄市里面的反弹
它都会就雄市基础是经济不好
经济衰退就是雄市
所以每一次雄市里的反弹
都像乒乓球砸在那个楼梯上一样
弹起来会弹很高
然后就掉下去
弹越掉越低
所以在我觉得在雄市和牛市
我都奉劝一句很重要的话
就要有耐心
要足够足够的耐心
有足够的耐心就是你不需要抄底
牛市里面足够的耐心就是拿着你不要动
你再下跌你别反弹
下跌你别去管它
那个但是雄市里面的耐心就是不要随便去抄底
但是我确实不确定这个政策也不确定性
那我自己个人仓位里面可能还将你30%不到
那个我也不会动
那个这是比昂说
我当然会讲美股非常长期的看法
我觉得美股非常长期的看法
还是缘优于全球所有的equal
所有全球的股票
在贸易战的美国优先的贸易战这个下面
受伤的就是直接对抗的是中国和美国
受伤的是受伤伤害最大的中国
但是中国有可能整得住腾
但是那个其他的国家可能更忍不住腾
那整个市场的市场最后就是回回过来的话
长远我我会觉得美国的equal没有那么大的问题
所以我的个人的投资呢
就是在美股里面还保留一些仓位
但同时的话我的那个港股的put
你确实是已经 out of money
从很远的 out of money 已经到英的马里了
所以这个可能是你们要看一下自己的资产配置
那如果说你完全是美股纯多的
那我建议是如果是完全美股纯多的
那我建议很低的仓位或者不要有仓位
因为现在可能没到底
那个如果是港股纯多的建议快跑
你今天就跑别管
你不管什么价钱跑都没事
这是个人的看法
那个那个反正我我个人看法
但是你们根据自己风险偏好去调整
美国市我觉得短期里面确实是会有犯态的
那么哪些因素是重要的呢
经济数据不重要
没有用那个能防配合不重要
美联储出来讲上周美联储那个绝跑说是关税影响的
关税增加和经济影响的这个这个东西
关税增加和经济的影响
将会远大于一切对经济的影响会远大于一切
那意思就是说这个我们现在这个经济数据
没有那么重要
我要密切关注这关税对于经济和对于通胀影响会多大
所以市场也没人看能防配合
这代表过去是代表拜登带来的经济政策
原来下面的经济的延续是什么样子
那个川普经济政策出来这个不知道什么样子
那简单解读一下这个recipical tariff它的是个什么东西
它其实就是看你对于美国进出口了多少
除以除以你跟美国的贸易量
那么就说你对你的贸易量下对美国进出口越大
你的税率越高
也就是说原来中国表示说给可以出口到越南
然后转口到美国对吧
然后现在如果你出口到越南转口到美国
那你越南的对美国的关税的笔中
就进出口的笔中就变大了
进出口名誉的笔中变大了
那么越南就要被加更大的关税
让所有的出口国自己去内卷
这个是这个关税的本质
那么内卷和围堵中国
所以包括我们知道越南现在去和那个美国谈关税
美国开的条件就是给中国加30%到50%的关税
那呃欧洲加拿大甚至欧洲加拿大极左的政府在内
他们其实都对美国腐软就是这一次都腐软
都没有人跳出来说
直接给美国反制性的关税
有说但是现在都在与谈判的方式去解决这个问题
也就是其实大家都认可原来大家都在占美国便宜
包括不光是关税的问题
比方说有很多流转环节中间有什么消费税
有什么隐形的这种关税税物啊
或者这些那个增值税啊
每个地方明目不同啊
包括对于甚至美国的互联网企业
像那个那个加拿大欧洲都想去收什么
其实都是想去占他们的便宜
就是不占便宜吧
就是像美国的这个产品收水
对于确实呃
原来是有一些贸易的不平衡的
包括你看中国和美国的贸易的这个关税的数据
中国一直是关税远高
中国对美关税一直是远高于美国对华关税的
紧于是美国一直在养中国的制造业嘛
那么美国原来的制度也是希望养中国的制造业
因为中国的制造业能跟美国带来更便宜的商品
然后呢那个给美国大公司带来更好盈利
然后美国人可以去消费
那么但是呢
这个不符合自由品不符合共和党他们的这个基本国策
那全球所有的国家现在大家太多
就是跟美国去谈判
然后把这个谈判的解决问题来解决这个问题
那么呃呃
美国要谈判解决这个问题
因为美国关税马上加上来了嘛
我觉得要克服两方面的事情
就第一个呢
要重塑
那第一个是重塑每个国家自己的税务体系
那个重塑税务体系
他第一个政府要少收税
你要把各个流涨环节的这些这个真子税
这些东西取消
你不能光说对美国取消
不取消其他地方
他其实有这样一个体系
在欧洲已经设立了一个高税务的体系
对于商品消费都有高税务体系
这个高税务体系上面是左派的政府
左派的大政府需要花钱吧
需要养个非法医民
然后这些都是需要花钱的
然后这个钱就是收税收爽了
那你要把这个税务体系给重塑了
也不是一个简单的事情
第二个呢
要重塑全球贸易体系
全球贸易体系在于中国的商品流转到美国
他有可能流转到欧洲
再转到美国或流转东南亚
或在东南亚建厂流转到美国
现在反正你要把中国给封锁了
你要把全世界全部团结在一起
要去封锁掉中国
这件事情呢
现在看来大家对于
重塑贸易体系对美国一起封锁中国都接手
欧洲加拿大这些地方都接手
就是包括他们去谈
美国也开这个条件
但是第一件事情是需要时间来解决的
所以整个市场会进入一个混乱阶段
就是谈判
然后谈得通 谈不通
谈得妥 谈不妥
然后中国反制
中国有给美国一个反制
加盘是34%的关税
就是这两边主要的假方和以方两边还杠上了
就是属于两边杠上的结果很容易脆断
这个是一个很危险的事情
拿根树枝两边
两个人又互相施加力气
然后就把折断
所以
我觉得现在市场来看
那个我们叫tail risk
并没有完全被爆发出来
中国在说4月10号给美国反制34%的关税了
然后trump说给中国再加50%
所以我觉得吧
就是这件事情两边其实都是
怎么说的
小学生拿枪对了对方
都是真的会开枪了
我很喜欢一个电影
人员星球
Planet of Ape
然后中间后面有一个情节
就是这个人员Ceezer
Ceezer是一个比较亲人类的人员
他清除了内部的这个背叛的人以后
人跟他讲你快走吧
要不然要打仗
那个让他走
然后Ceezer的给他的回应是
我还是比刚
这个战争已经开始了
因为他作为员的领袖
他也没有办法
他必须接受这个战争
很多时候不是说你一个人的政治立场是怎么样的
或者是trump的政治立场
他是要捞钱
或者是伊隆马斯的政治立场
最好是和中国合作
不是的
当你使用民粹
你就开启使用黑魔法
你使用黑魔法
你就要被黑魔法侵蚀
你要在中国同样的道理
你说我们使用民粹的人
最最就是使用民粹的人在中国
比较说反美反日那些人
他也被民意绑架
他也没有办法回头
其实是不是大家想使用民粹反美
走到今天这一步
我觉得上面未必想
但是走下去他就没有办法
一样美国也没有什么办法
当你所有的共和党的这些大后面金主
可能都有中国利益
但是没有办法的
包括民主党现在反共和党
跟共和党也杠赏
等他们杠完以后
如果真的能够执政
他对中国态度只会更差
不会更好
他一定也要杠赏
因为没有办法
这个就是民意
那个当你为所有人都是政客的
最优化不是拿经济来优化
政客最优化是拿选漂亮优化
所以这个是对于中美关系
一个非常大的一个悲观的点
在中国的边也有这样的问题
在美国这边也有这样的问题
在中国
就我今天早上还说到一个事情
就是大家不知知不知道
那个南京保卫战
就是二战的时候
南京被大屠杀
但其实起初的时候是
中国军队要去守南京
那个当时蒋介石
白宗席
李宗仁都说不能守
其实李宗仁和白宗席都说不能守
蒋介石不知可否
也一开始同意说不守
但是有个叫唐深智的人跳出来说
我要与南京共成王
我们怎么可以抛弃自己首度
抛弃郑宗山先生的邻请呢
当你有政治正确的声音出来的时候
理性的声音是没有办法发生的
那只能够服从政治正确的声音
那中国我觉得有同样的问题
你知道你守南京的结果是什么的
大家不傻都知道守南京的结果是什么
但是没有人能够跳出来反对他干这个事情
这就是可悲之处
中国也一样
你今天给美国加34%的关税
你知道美国一定会反制你
而且你知道美国反制你之后
你不可能服软
因为你第一步不服软
第二步怎么服软
你不可能服软
但是你不得不干这个事情
因为所有知道做这件事情不对的人
他如果反对
他就有可能有政治的风险
那这个才是就是决策体制的这个问题
决策体制的风险
那么原来美国和英国都有一个
很好的决策体制
来说没有永远的朋友
只有永远的利益
没有永远的朋友
没有永远敌人
只有永远的利益
他一直是处于一个极为理智的状态
英美的政治体制
和所有的过往的那个外交史
他一定是非常非常理智
他就只有理智
只有理
没有那个没有那个感情用事
但是呢
现在美国国内的左派和右派护钢
就是互相杠上
指的现在外交政策上面
在右派的外交政策上面
或者以后左派的外交政策上面
他必须要考虑到这些失业的民粹
那这些民粹都是对着中国去的
所以当有人用了黑魔法
你你GOP用了
以后民主党也要用了
那中美的这个
这个两边都是处于这个黑魔法的
这个互相使用互相伤害的过程
那这个过程是不会停
所以说到全球的资产
那我就说一个更加长远的时候
第一个首先你要有足够耐心啊
我这里反复重复
就是要足够耐心
意味着你可能会看到一个很大的反弹
但你不要动心
因为衰退下面反弹是没有意义的
这个东西还是会下去的
但是什么情况下
我觉得是一个市场时机呢
这个市场时机存在于
呃呃首先你我们现在杀的是估值
盈利还没掉
因为你开2025年的话
整体市场预期9%
这个8%到9%的这个
Growth增长预期
盈利增长预期我就达不到的
如果是按照我刚刚讲的衰退的情况
0-3%就是不错的
所以你现在先杀了估值之后
还要杀Ernie
还要杀EPS
所以EPS的下跌
就是EPS的下跌是第二个
那么在整个市场的下跌的时候
你要找就好像水桶
或者是我们叫防洪地里面
最薄弱的那一环
薄弱那环会被冲倒
然后导致整个地霸全部决定
那个中国和美国两边互掐
其实这次贸易战
本质上是美国掐全世界
但是最最核心的掐中国
所以是中国美国互掐
中国的忍痛能力很强的
中国忍痛能力强
并不在于说中国经济会好
而是说中国对于能够忍受更差的经济
而不造成大问题
继续执行它的认测
这么说中国能够忍受经济
比方说衰退10%
还能够执行自己的证册
这个在全世界没有一个国家能做得到
所以中国忍痛能力很强
所以在这个水桶里面
中国和美国都不会崩
美国经济是最好
它是假方
假方怎么会崩呢
假方如果要去掐以防
它受的苦肯定比以防少
所以假方以防
大假方和大以防都不会崩
老大掐老二老三老四老五倒霉
所以后面我觉得可能倒霉是东南亚
可能是欧洲
欧洲现在已经开始对中国说
准备收倾销性关税
因为知道中国这个商品出不去
美国要来欧洲了
所以已经开始搞这个中国和欧洲的关税
它跟美国是谈判
跟中国是说征收关税
然后更大的问题可能发生在东南亚
因为东南亚第一个是靠投资
这些年中国有一些产业移到哪里去
靠投资
第二靠对美国的贸易
它也非常依赖外贸
但是美国对东南亚也进行了贸易战
那么这个贸易战的结果是
没人敢再去那个什么印尼马来西亚投资
马来西亚加把人的死
印尼加了32
这个怎么投
你包括越南现在也被加了46
这些地方你就没有办法继续做投资
你会非常担心
然后外贸也会受到影响
在他们就是来回跟美国的谈判
过程完成之前
他受到的苦可能会更大
再加上金融市场的真的冲击下来的话
他们的下跌的幅度可能会比中国下跌
不无所谓
你港股你就要跌一半
港股我觉得很有可能从顶部
你要说港股很深
H9000都要9000 20万
我9000做的put跌到45000
这个我觉得没有问题的
这真的是出几端情况
我觉得可以跌很多
现在已经到7000多了
7000多了
那个但是中国能忍住
其他国家未必能忍得住
所以我说预演这个危机的过程
是先跌的是美国
因为政策处在美国
美股已经跌了两三星期了
跌完以后全球的资产都会重新定价
包括这个对于主要是对于中国
或者说日本啊
这些全又全部重新定价
这个重新定价之后呢
是这是极跌
跌完可能会反弹
会过一段时间
然后发生美国调整估值
调整EPS 调整盈利
美国调整盈利之后再跌
那美国调整盈利之后的
这一轮的下跌是不一定会这么急
但是会缓缓的一直下跌
你可以看参考2002年
2002年SNP的反弹
那个纳斯达克的反弹是非常距离的
他反弹很快
然后但是后面从4000点
还是给你跌到1400
那这个是over一年两年的过程
那他那次的衰退时间更长
美联储完全没有办法介入
现在美联储我觉得这样
完全不介入的可能不太大
所以不一定会有那么长时间
但是还是要有足够的人来行
他是会要见到什么样的信号呢
就是我觉得见到当洪水
索拉米这个海啸
冲垮地霸的最薄弱那一环
导致信贷问题
信贷问题意味着某家银行倒了
不管他是巴西的哪家银行
阿根廷的银行
然后哪个国家债务default
违约了
阿根廷不一定会违约
阿根廷以前的状况还行
比方说巴西违约了
或者是欧洲什么希腊违约了
意大利违约
那你发生这种情况的时候
他的冲击是会到金融体系内的
那你会再一次面对
就是你现在这个下跌是满跌
然后反弹
然后慢慢满跌
出源可能关上问题
然后这个关税政策
我刚刚讲过不太会取消
不太会取消呢
中国美国杠着
杠着之后
其他国家催断
催断以后
那个你慢慢跌了之后
发现一下子满跌
那个就是金融体系里面出现问题
那个时候我觉得可以可以考虑
就是去去超低
所以你要等这样的信号之前
是要有足够的耐心
这个耐心就是你会看到
猛烈的下跌完了以后
现在这个位置上反弹了
反弹你就忍住
然后接着慢慢跌
慢慢跌
你每天想都要去超低
但是忍住
直到一定要有发生催断事件
就是发生金融体系里面的催断事件
发生EPS调整事件
就是我们的盈利预期全部被调整
盈利预期全部被调整
那讲的比较悲观吧
我讲一点乐观
就是对于那个
特别是对于美国
对于美国科技公司
对于Mega7
那个一个乐观的东西
就是说你可能会看到
像2023年这种
那像这里这种
至少看到2022年底这种
这个Elinger Gross
然后整个市场的调整
我觉得可能会看到
而且概率很大
因为现在你别说关税
关税之外
你现在已经股票上刷掉10万亿了
那你这些财富的损失
一定会转化成消费的损失
转化成投资的损失
这是毫无疑问
那么这一些东西呢
会导致大量的失业
但是失业的工作
会被人光智能取代的
现在我们在工业革命
你想我们最早的时候
工业革命的时候
杨痴什么那个杨痴人的故事
不就是那个英国最早杨痴人的故事
机器痴人的故事
不是一次次的在商业吗
所以你当你一次大的危机
把那些本来在劳动岗位上的人
给出清
这市场上出清掉以后
他会被其他东西取代
而不是被原来的人力取代
所以你可能会看到
原来你在做会计
你最近日子过得不错
你在做比方说
在做律师事务性律师
然后你在做白领
你在做一些这个这个这个
办公室的工作
这些工作被全部出清以后
发现机器人把这个东西全取代
机器人用的是什么
AI用的是什么
AI用的是Mercosoft
用的是Google
用的是Metal和Amazon
用了他们的用算力中心
所以就好像这一波2022年
2022年的时候
我们看到的出清是很多尸体
所以尸体的东西
在美国一旦被互联网取代
就是互联网的
就是TMT的这些大公司
那这一轮也是
工作都会被他们取代
所以所以你说
长期来说是不是看好
还是看好的
美国企业是
美国公司是这个
特别互联网公司
大公司是看好的
但是短期他们有很多的挣痛
他会被欧盟去加税
因为反制性的关税
不一定加在美国商品上
可以加在美国服务上
可以加在你的互联网企业上面
这个变数今天虽然
欧洲在说谈
中国也在说谈
中国已经没有互联网
美国互联网没有生态到中国
中国早就把人家全掐死了
但是大家虽然说在谈
但是谈的过程会有很多的反复的
因为你要改变人家税制
你等于干涉人家内政和意识形态
这个事情是需要过程的
那么这个过程里面会有很多反复
所以他的挡痛肯定没走完
但是挡痛走完之后
目标就是这些科技公司
而且科技公司现在固执杀了很凶
他的盈利被杀了可能没有那么凶
这个和2022
我上次可能会议的时候就讲过这问题
可能2022年很像的
他反而在第二轮下跌
经济真正变差下跌的时候
他是defensive的
他是有保护性的
所以这个是我个人看法
所以市场上要有足够耐性
如果你认为这个是穷事
关税这种东西出来是穷事
我们之前的基本面判断
年初的时候我一直基本面判断
我一直说effective tariff4%到5%
我觉得可能的情况
上周的时候我觉得可能10%到15%
现在他直接将近20%
所以这个是一个game changer
如果你认为这个game changer不会变
那么这个就是一个要有耐性的穷事
但是你要等我刚刚讲的信号
这个信号之后
你是能够看到这些标的
一定是最好的标的
不会是港股的标的
香港是最惨的
就是港股和中概股这些最惨的
就爹和妈在打架
儿子不会好过的
所以这个才是最惨的
能够看的标的
眼睛永远盯着是美国的科技大公司
好吧
我今天先讲到这里